ومعنا من عمان نقلي واق فايزه دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك
اللواء الدويري لليوم الثاني القرم في
مرمى الاستهداف الاوكراني كيف يمكن قراءه
ذلك
يعني اولا شبه جزيره القرم والتقرير جاء
على اهميتها الاستراتيجيه في البعدين
العسكري وسياسي ولكن اقول هناك مجموعه من
العوامل
تدفع اوكرانيا لاستهداف شبه جزيره القرم
بصوره مكثفه وشبه دائمه اولا قرب مسافه
القرم من نقاط انطلاق الطائرات المسيره او
الصواريخ او الزوارق البحريه او الضفادع
البشريه الامر الاخر شبه جزيره القرم اذا
نظرنا لها ككتله واحده تعتبر هدف وائل هدف
واهل يمكن الوصول اليه باقل التكاليف
واحتماليه النجاح عاليه لماذا مساحه القرن
27 الف كيلو متر مربع توجد بها نقاط حيويه
ذات اهميه قصوى لادامه واداره المعركه
يوجد بها ميناء سوفيستوبيل يوجد بها جسر
كيرش يوجد بها قواعد عسكريه يوجد بها
قواعد لوجستيك امداديه الامداد وبالتالي
قروبها يمكن الطائرات المسيره من الوصول
وهي رخيصه التكاليف ويمكن ان تتقرب من
زوايا
اقتراب مختلفه هي ضمن مدى صواريخ ظل
العاصفه هي ضمن اطار استخدام المسيرات
البحريه والضفادع البشريه هذه العوامل
تجعل امكانيه الوصول سهله ضمن قدرات الجيش
الاوكراني وتبعات فيما اذا نجح صاروخ من
اصل سته كما حدث يوم امس يرسل رساله قويه
اذا نجح صاروخ او زورق بحري في الوصول الى
سفينه انزال يرسل رساله اذا الهدف واهل
صعب الدفاع عنه بصوره مطلقه امكانيه
الوصول اليه باقل التكاليف تجعل اولويه
ترقى في البعد العسكري عن مدينه موسكو وان
كانت موسكو تتقدم عليه بالبعد السياسي وما
هي اذا هذه الرسائل التي تود اكياس
توجيهها لموسكو من خلال استهداف شبه جزيره
القرم بصواريخ اغلبها لا يصيب الاهداف
يعني اولا الرساله الاولى واشار لها
التقرير بيكون وضوح ان القرم هي عرض
اوكرانيه منذ عام 1953 ولا يمكن التنازل
عليه عنها وهي وفقا لقوانين هيئه الامم
المتحده اثنين التركيز عليها يذكر العالم
ان هناك اعتداء وهذا الاعتداء لم يبدا قبل
عامين انما بدا قبل سنوات قبل ما يقارب
عقد من الزمن ثم السيطره على القرن تم
السيطره على شكل شرق دون باس ولكن ما جرى
في شباط 2022 هو اكمال الدوره العملياتي
الروسيه اي بمعنى اخر ان الاطباع الروسيه
ليست انيه وليست مؤثره ومحدده جغرافيا
ولذا على العالم الحر كما يقول
الاوكرانيين ان يناصرنا بكل قدراته من اجل
احتواء هذا التضخم الروسي والبحث عما يطلق
عليه الفيلسوف دوجن بروسيا الجديده
الرسائل الاوكرانيه ماذا عن موسكو وكيف
تتلقى هذه الصواريخ في شبه جزيره القرم
الى اي مدى تقلقها هذه الصواريخ
الان كيف تتلقاها احنا الان سنتبنى او
نتوقف عند التصريحات الروسيه تصريحات
الروسيه دائما تخفف من حده الامر بالامس
قيل بان هناك جندي فقد وخمس جرحوا لانه
الحقيقه هي دائما الغائبه في صراع الروسي
الاوكراني اذا وضعنا البيانات حول نفس
النقطه نجد هناك فجوه كبيره لا يمكن
تجسيرها بينما الجانب الاوكراني يقول لا
كان هناك اجتماع للقاده تم قتل تسعه منهم
قاده في مناصب متقدمه عندما تم تدمير جسر
كرش قالوا بان الاضرار بسيطه لكن كانت
الاضرار كبيره وتحتاج الى اسابيع لاعاده
الترميم والاصلاح الشامل اذا الاعلان
الروسي يخفف من الوطاه لكن هي تحاول ان
تتعايش مع هذا الواقع
تكثف الشبكات الانذار تكثف القدرات الجويه
للدفاع عن القرن لكن في النهايه مهما بذلت
لان الامن المطلق غير موجود سيتم اختراقه
سيتم مهاجمه اهداف وان تباينت رغم ان
التركيز على
هدفينش اشكرك جزيل الشكر لواء فايزه دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه حدثنا من
عمان